so
uh if i can start with a couple quick
questions first
um how many of you would say you deal
with message processing either
online or offline can i get a show of
hands
okay so most everyone how many of you
deal with xml data regularly
no hands one hand good how many of you
deal with json messages regularly
how many of you deal with other types of
messages regularly
okay so far a number of people cool
um so we're gonna start off we're gonna
i guess i should do a little intro
myself uh i head up the
infrastructure team at bitly and uh
that team is focused on a lot of our
back-end systems and keeping them up and
running
scaling them up and keeping them
performant
so nsq is a project that we've written
to help with a lot of sort of the
communication between our different
systems
we'll talk about that a little bit and
uh this is
uh snakes also known as matt at
whichever direction you want to
play that who has written most of nsq
and is also partner in crime on that so
and you guys know what bitly is right
it's the little short urls
right so most of the data that is a
result of those clicks or those new
links that are created
flows through the system this is stuff
that's in production we use it day in
day out
i think we hit peaks of roughly 80 000
messages a second so just to put that in
perspective what we're talking about
um so i'm going to start
by describing just briefly a little bit
of how we
uh approach systems at bitly
um we sort of call this the way of the
bitly
um so we have a little bit of a
philosophy in how we orient things
is that your computer making noise here
something's ringing it's probably
facetime
i mean it looks like the camera is on oh
well
we're going to ignore that for a while
uh so a little bit of
sort of the philosophy that we have at
bitly and how we approach systems
we like to try to break things down into
small individual services that do one
thing
and they do does it well and then sort
of organize all those different
individual services to make up bitly as
a whole and
so that sort of fits into nsq is one of
those individual
sort of pieces that helps us and uh so
those are just
a little bit of the things we like to do
we like to do as much work
asynchronously as we can we use
http and json a lot we like it because
it's flexible it's easy to scale
so i'm going to talk a little bit of
what a typical data flow looks like
generally anytime you're building sort
of a web app or anything with
sort of a front end you have some sort
of incoming request
that hits your application your
application you know was built to do
something
talks to a database whatever it needs to
do responds with
you know whatever the result is that's
sort of like your
your initial work for an application uh
but then what we like to do
is we like to structure this fourth
piece which is any
uh sort of like anything you can do
asynchronously or any sort of like audit
trail of
the work that an application is due and
we like to
uh treat that as sort of the beginnings
of
our asynchronous message processing and
so really
nsq fills in the framework that we use
to sort of take messages from an
application
and then go do things with it so we're
really going to be talking about this
fourth section okay so let's talk about
some common messaging patterns
first up is the pub sub model so this
would be
a producer writing into some service
and that service would be copying that
exact same message
and delivering it to the consumers that
are subscribed
so they're duplicated right this is if
you want to have multiple systems that
are interested in
uh the same type of message maybe
they're performing some different work
maybe one of them is incrementing some
database
one of them might be archiving the
messages
do you want to talk through some
examples here uh
examples yeah so uh like as as we go
through these slides
i think we'll try to talk through a
little bit of a example case you can
sort of
think through how this works out um so
say in our case
epitly we have a producer which is uh
the application that
receives a click on a bitly link and
redirects the user
so that click event we capture in a
message
and so multicast is used when you want
to sort of take that message
duplicate it to separate systems that
each want a copy of that message
so you can imagine one system might do
metrics and sort of do incrementing on
it and another system
might just be for like long-term
archival and
archiving that out to disk and you know
going back to the philosophy slide
obviously these groups of consumers that
compose the service consumer a set of
consumers a set of consumers be
they're decoupled from each other so
they're independent set of hosts
independent instead of applications
different languages whatever
next up distribution so this would be a
producer writing a
series of messages into a queue and that
cue handing out
different messages to different
consumers so this would be load
balancing them for example
so you could imagine a single group of
consumers like jahi's example before
where there is
some system that increments some clicks
database
you can continue to add consumers until
you're you know meeting the needs of
whatever the volume is coming in
able to easily scale the system and then
of course distribution as well provides
some sort of fall tolerance
so if consumer a disappears i'm consumer
yeah one of consumer a
disappears the other one will take up
the responsibilities
get the messages that were in the queue
and continue processing
and then obviously if both of them
disappear the queue serves the
responsibility of
buffering those messages and hanging on
to them until you operationally fix the
system
or uh ladder can you just get into that
sorry i was saying um
in this case the queue would hang onto
those messages buffer them
and provide a layer for you to recover
from the situation
introduce new consumers
and fix the system so sort of
philosophically like
when uh we're dealing with different
independent systems we need something
that sort of
can sit between them so that they're not
tightly coupled
because it would be pretty terrible if
we had
say we had some issues incrementing
metrics and if that sort of
blocked us from redirecting a user and
sort of accepting that click
that would be pretty bad so part of the
goal of
making that asynchronous is so that when
we're not able to increment our metrics
quite as fast as we'd like
we have a spot to sort of keep that
information and it's not affecting
uh the producer the other really
important thing here is that this isn't
just failure scenarios right
so this could be something where the
system is slow the downstream system
that consumer a is running into
uh you know it doesn't always have to be
complete and out of failure where you
don't have any consumers who are able to
uh process these messages
and uh we'll talk i'll give a little
demo at the end uh there's a lot of
operational
pieces where you really want the ability
to sort of pause an entire system
and uh you can think of that as sort of
pausing a cue
you're still accepting uh messages but
you're not giving any messages out
so what are typical architectures that
do this sort of thing look like
and uh between you and me this is
actually our old architecture we just
didn't label the components
appropriately so you have host a you
have some api service like
i was describing before excuse a message
we actually used to put our
we still do we put our workers on the
same host so that's one silo right
that might be load balance in front of
it um
and then we have some sort of relay
that writes to some intermediate host
maybe that's our pub sub demon
so that you know like-minded consumers
can
get those messages and then you have
another host
relaying that to another queue and then
another worker processing
some you know doing some work clicks
archiving
uh data you know data sciency stuff and
this could be n number of hosts right
you could have
15 of these host cs doing many different
things from this pub sub
uh and you can see this is pretty
complicated right and there's also a
couple interesting things here
right so you have a couple single points
of failure you have the complexity of
having to set this up over and over
again for all of the
subsystems that you want and a bunch of
hard-coded configuration
any any questions so far i should
mention before feel free to uh
raise your hand if you have any
questions while we're going on here
um yes maybe no i think
who was first go ahead uh
what would this stack look like what
were you writing this first
um so at bitly we use python really
heavily
so a lot of sort of the work we would do
on messages
we do in python um a lot of sort of the
pieces that would do some of the message
communication in the queuing was a lot
of
c code written on top of events
this old solution
just to say the questions you guys can
all hear the question was
uh was the cue we were using persistent
that was one of the problems fix your
systems quickly don't let it fill up
so those were some of uh so that was
sort of what
we used to have historically and you can
sort of imagine those are sort of
individual pieces
that you would end up with if you have a
very distributed services
architecture so nsq is what we built to
sort of
improve that whole situation uh so we're
going to talk a little bit of sort of
what
uh what we wanted to get out of nsu when
we started writing it
so obviously we talked a little bit
before of
both the ability to do multicast so
different services could each get their
copy of messages
and also the wanting the ability to
distribute as well so an individual
service can kind of grow horizontally
and be able to consume its copy of the
messages in aggregate
and then we also talked about queuing so
that
you can handle the flow of messages
between different systems when there's a
mismatch
and then i do want to talk to you yeah
so i mean one of the really important
ones you have to remember this
the system that we sort of pseudo
described before that was running in
production doing the same thing that nsq
does now for us
so it was really important for whatever
thing we used to replace it to sort of
fit in that same puzzle piece
so that guided some of the decisions we
ended up making in terms of
the api we exposed for you to interact
with it
and obviously like we spoke about before
the
configuration requirements of that old
system were were you know
way too much for the average developer
to be able to stand up a system
uh get access to the messages that they
wanted and you know do some work
uh and as the gentleman asked before
what is the cue persistent the old one
wasn't so we wanted a way for us to
bound the messages that would be stored
in memory and write the overflow to disk
so you had a much
you know larger window of time that you
could recover from failure scenarios
uh yeah and also sort of a little bit
to the answer of your question we do try
to do things a lot
at bitly that are very language agnostic
between
different services which is why we like
to use http and json between our
services as much as possible
there have been several cases in the
past where we've taken something in
python rewriting it in c
or rewritten it in wrote it and go
and it's really nice to not be tied to
something that's very like tightly
coupled at the language
level also one of the reasons why we use
http and json right
most languages have good library support
for that so
if we were sort of to boil down our
goals and what we wanted to get out of
it
we wanted everything right we wanted
that
last one
yeah so topology what we mean there is
uh
anytime you're dealing with more than
one server
you have to sort of decide what your
message topology looks like
you know do you go through do all your
messages go through a single broker
are they sort of created across more
than one host are they consumed across
more than one host and sort of like what
the message flow
looks like from you know the point of
origin to where the messages end up
right
so that's what we mean by topology
um and there's certainly pieces of that
that you want to be as decoupled as
possible right you don't want
your the source of your messages to
necessarily be writing the message
directly to whatever service needs them
in the end
because then you're sort of like every
time you add a new service that means
those messages you have to update your
source
and if that source is something you want
to sort of leave alone which in our case
uh so in the clicks example that source
is our core piece of the stack that does
the redirects on a bitly link every time
we want access to those messages we
don't want to have to update that and
say hey
go copy it to this new service go send
another copy to this other service
like we want a topology that separates
those out
does that answer your question and also
speaking to the data sciencey part of
things right you want to be able to have
easy access to that data right
even data in production like a live feed
of the bitly clicks which we'll actually
demo later
um the easier you can make that access
the better it is for people who are
trying to consume it
so yeah so what did we build we built
so we just wanted to be fast
well so part of part of uh in terms of
throughput
right there's different ways to think of
that really what we wanted out of it
was a way to scale horizontally right
which means it doesn't really matter
what your actual throughput is on an
individual piece
you just add more right so
we didn't want to be sort of
like we don't like getting stuck or we
just need sort of a bigger box or
like a faster tool we've got to rewrite
an assembly to get it faster like we
don't want to be stuck in those
situations
we want to have like good tools that let
us spread things out
so and i guess also a little bit to the
topology question
we like to end up when we say
distributed we
really like to end up with distributed
things that are completely independent
and uncoordinated right so there are a
lot of different
ways you could take the word distributed
but for us
it means sort of independently like
uncoordinated horizontally scaling
i don't know if that helps answer your
question don't get me wrong though it's
fast it is fast
yeah i mean it's a goal it's not the
only goal though right
single note on my laptop four hundred
thousand messages a second
i mean that's not bad right i mean it
should be enough for a lot of use cases
yeah so i'm sure guys you know about the
you know
brand and q or
i knew there would be those questions
man
uh right so nsq uh
how many of you write and go yeah that
was the
homage to the little golan gopher in the
corner nobody caught that that makes me
sad but it's okay
um so hold on i have other language
questions
you write in c regularly
so now we're going to start talking
about some nsq stuff nitty gritty so
please again just ask questions if
things don't make sense um
so nsq has the concept of a topic and a
channel
and this is our way of combining the
multicast
distribution and cueing uh behaviors
that we talked about before
you can think of a topic as this
distinct stream of messages something
like clicks
something like new encodes for bitly
something like an api request an api
request
right and then on those topics inside an
nsqd daemon
you add channels so channels are
independent cues
for that topic so each one is getting a
copy of the messages
so you could imagine a downstream system
that wants to increment metrics
it has a channel on the clicks topic
spam analysis and again archive we just
have a habit of archiving all the
streams that we produce
and then you add some consumers to that
you keep adding them and that's your
distribution yeah this is where you
distribute
your messages so all of a consumer
sort of gets in aggregate will get all
of its messages
so you can imagine you have message a
coming through the system
into the clicks topic gets copied
to all of those channels
and then goes to a single consumer
message b
comes into the clips topic copied to all
the channels
and then delivered to a potentially
different consumer right so you see
the multicast and distribution
and one of the nice things about this
setup is that they're all created at
runtime so if you publish a message for
the clicks topic
to a demon that otherwise didn't know
about that topic before it would be
created at runtime
same thing on the subscription side so
if a consumer logs in and he says hey i
want
i want clicks i'm on the metrics channel
that stuff will be created at runtime
this helps later as you'll see for
things like introspection
no no there uh that's probably an
improvement i can make to that slide
thank you but
you can have many many of those many
topics many channels
and we often do that's typical
so like i was saying before each channel
is an independent queue so
the consumers that are participating on
the metrics channel for the clix topic
right that guy
they can fail and recover and back up
and and re-queue messages and and
process successfully
independently from the spam analysis
channel for example right so if spam
analysis is having
issues with its downstream database or
uh
maybe there's a host failure or
something like that
trying to get to the next slide again
this is where you start to see
the ability to in in terms of how you
handle your messages
still decouple your systems right and
that's all inside of single dna so each
of those
you know channels gets its own cue and
to answer this gentleman's question
before
uh you can configure a high-water mark
for a
the demon actually so it applies to all
the topics and channels
and above that high water mark measured
in messages things will be written to
disk
typically we set this to ten thousand or
so nobody subscribes to a token
topic is a queue as well they're all
cues so the there's no channels yet that
it will cue at the topic
the first channel will get those
messages we have ways that we
handle that consistency and let the
subscribers catch up
to what was not messages that were
processed already this is uh
not used for that purpose but it's a
good question
right yeah
the topics could be the topic
so the topic is really just sort of
think of it as like a label of how
you're describing a certain type of
message
not necessarily no there's nothing
precluding some topology that would
uh would it would affect performance for
the consumers that were on
the network partition right i would
imagine if you're going to do something
like that
you'd have independent sets of consumers
for that topic that is spread across a
number of data centers
i mean you could structure it that way i
mean at some point i would imagine you'd
want to aggregate them
or maybe not i don't know what we often
do is we
relay topics across data center
boundaries so if we
if we're producing a message like its
origin in our
you know core data center that handles
decodes we'll relay that over to
aws and do some data science on it for
example
a bunch of demons participate in a
cluster
to produce that topic
i think some of that will be a little
clearer in a few minutes so
ask again later if you don't if you
still have questions there
so we're going to talk through a little
bit of some of the details of how
nsq sort of laid out topology wise how
the details of discovery and is handled
between
both the clients that want a message and
the demons
the nsq demons that have messages for a
given topic
so if we look at this when a producer
gets a message
your producer is sending that message
over to nsqd and it's saying what topic
that message is
and then an ascuti will connect out to
the lookup demons you've configured and
it will
sort of identify and register saying
i've got messages for this
topic same thing will happen
when it has a channel too and then
from the consumer side the consumer is
able to connect
out to the lookup demon say where
are the producers that have this topic
i'm interested in
and then it's able to use that
information and go to connect so
the lookup demon is your sort of broker
of what
topics are where in your topology and
that allows you to sort of
uh disconnect your
consumers from your publishers and they
don't have to know anything about each
other
except the topic of the messages they
want
simplifying configuration right so you
have this set of
lookup hosts performing this dns like
service for the
the cluster
so how this works out with multiple
demons
you have multiple linus qd's the
consumer will
connect to each of them and it'll get
messages from each of them so if i have
the clicks topic that we've been talking
through as an example and that's being
published on
three hosts the consumer will connect
and get those messages from all three
hosts
so there's no coordination between the
individual message demons
that's handled by the consumer from
consuming from
all the sources that have the topic it's
interested in
and again like jahi was mentioning
before uh one important property of the
lookup demons are that they don't
coordinate either
so those are all independent hosts
demons and the information that you
retrieve from the set of them you union
together to identify the
you know the entire list of producers
that you're going to connect to and
subscribe
and we don't talk about a lot but in for
us uh it's fairly important that
this is a real time system which means
that messages have to be pushed
through the system and not pulled so
as soon as an nsqd gets that message it
has
a from the consumers that are interested
in that message
and it will immediately write that
message out to a consumer that's ready
for messages
and we'll talk a little bit more later
about how consumers
notify it that they're ready do you have
a question yeah question is if
r2 is hosted inside an sqd and what
happens is that
that d1 goes down because the queue is
duplicated across multiple
full tolerances the nsu doesn't make
that decision for you
so there are a couple ways you can
mitigate the the message loss you're
talking about
he asked the question of uh if a node
disappears what happens
um you can set your high water mark
really low
so most of your message if there's a
huge backlog are buffered on disk
so then you're talking about an entire
host failure in order to lose those
messages
like if it rebooted it would obviously
replay the ones that are on disk
um and you can you can use other
strategies to publish to multiple
independent nodes
if you want if you know it depends on
the requirements right it's really
it's trade-offs and certainly like there
are cases where you care a lot about
the durability of your messages but in
terms of a real-time message queue you
sort of expect
your queues to always be at zero right
the goal is not that it has a regular
steady you know a million messages in
the queue the goal is in terms of
uh real time systems the goal is that it
always has zero messages right
like i mean the times where you have
need the cue
is when you're sort of dealing with some
sort of failure scenario so that's one
piece of it
and so that helps when you know we
mentioned before
one of the things we almost always do is
one of the channels
getting messages for a topic is just
archiving it out to disk
right so as long as he's caught up
uh he's getting a copy of the messages
written out to him on the wire as soon
as it comes in
even if the other applications that are
sort of waiting for those messages
are backed up and then asked you know is
killed and you lose those messages
you've already written them out to some
system that has an archival of them so
there are a lot of ways to sort of
handle that you can also set
the depth at which you want messages
written out to be zero
if you really want that you're also
persisting those things in a distributed
way right so you have
a channel dedicated to archiving you
could have multiple channels dedicated
to archiving each
independent right on an independent set
of
posts across availability zones in aws
really because the question of your
defaults
it's giving you the primitives to do it
in a healthy way
so i guess the question is are you using
this for both those two
use cases yes so how do you do
everything is completely decoupled and
they don't
coordinate how do you know that say the
same message isn't
sent to two
so the each individual nsqd will only
give that message out to one
right for a channel for a channel right
so your channel
the consumers of a channel get
distributed sort of round robin or like
whichever one's ready
but the message gets copied into each
channel so that it's your multicast from
your topic
to each of your channels and then from
your channel to the consumers it's
distributed so you only
it only gets given out once unless that
client says hey
i can't handle that message and gives it
back
separate consumers right those are
different messages though
right so the same thing happens on each
demon with messages
independently there's other there's two
other important things here that one is
that we typically
in our setup and what we tend to suggest
people do when they use nsq
is to publish locally right so if you
have like we were
demonstrating before if you have some
host that has your api application
that's
you know processing incoming api
requests it would write
to its local host and sqd because one of
the things we
try to avoid is uh for the application
that's creating metrics
or creating messages you don't want to
be stuck in a situation where
the outbound network is unavailable and
you don't have any choices with what you
can do with your message so we
normally run an nsqd
on the same instance as whatever
applications publishing
messages so it can always write locally
because that's sort of the highest
guarantee you have of availability is
sort of your local
on the same host and the other thing is
that uh we've i don't know if we've
explicitly said it but it's
at least once delivery so this means
that any other any number of things can
cause
the message to be redelivered we try to
avoid
no delivery right you can imagine if you
you know kill your consumer in the
middle of it handling a message
and ascuti will know that it did not get
an
acknowledgement and it'll hand that
message out again so there are some like
there's always edge cases in any sort of
message handling you either have at most
once or at least
once and so we are on the at least one
side
uh the next slide actually shows some of
this go ahead what's your question
how do you maintain the ordering of
messages
we don't no no guaranteed ordering uh
especially when you think about at least
once delivery
becomes a huge problem and then you have
to involve single points of failure and
brokers and
some window of time that you're willing
to tolerate uh easy things you can do
when you need information about
ordering or loose ordering which is just
put some of that information inside of
your message so put the time stamp in
there put like whatever granularity of
sort of ordering information you need
is really just the transport mechanism
uh they're on independent channels so
yes so he asked um if there are two sets
of consumers and one of them cares about
message
loss and one of them doesn't really care
about message loss how can you structure
that
so first you put them on two independent
channels right so you have this topic
clicks you have your
archive channel where you care about uh
message loss and you're
incrementing where you don't care so
much right your
clients that are doing the processing
for the incrementing channel
can just acknowledge the message and
perform work or not right
they can do that upfront before they do
the work and not base that decision to
acknowledge the message on whether or
not the processing succeeded
so let's talk through what all of these
different pieces
look like put together so i mentioned
before we like to have
whatever applications creating a message
publish locally
to uh nsqd and then the nsqd will
connect out to the lookup demon to sort
of
register that it has messages for a
given topic and that happens of course
you know the first message it gets
and then clients are able to query and
ask where to get messages for a given
topic
and then they connect directly to the
sources and the messages are pushed
to them so you can imagine here sort of
in as you scale up any of these pieces
your new clients are able to sort of
easily discover where
the message that they need to get if you
add a new producer that's
publishing information it'll register
that it has that topic
the clients poll regularly to ask what
sources have their topic and they're
able to pick up any new
topic sources so it's very easy
operationally to deal with
the topology of where your messages are
and where
they need to go were there questions on
that
right so as i was just talking about the
the message guarantee that nsu does
provide is that it will deliver it at
least once if nothing breaks um
what happens when nsq sends a client a
message is it
puts it off to the side still in memory
um
waits for the client to resp respond
either fin or req
and upon receiving one of those commands
it will
put it back onto the queue if it's
telling being told to re-cue or finish
the message and discard it
uh successfully finn can also be used in
the case that
the gentleman who asked that question
before to just say hey i'm i'll take
care of this don't worry about it
you could fin immediately when you
receive it and if a client disappears
or for any reason network is slow and
there are timeouts
there's a 60-second configurable
window of time where nsq will say hey i
haven't gotten an answer from you i'll
put that back on the queue
and that sort of put together provides
your guarantee
do the the lookup demons are they
redundant in some way i'm thinking so
the
the question about the look of demons is
are they redundant uh
they are redundant but they're not court
there's no coordination between them
because the nsqd's uh register
information with all the lookup demons
their coordinate they're
configured with and then on the client
side you just union the information you
get back from them
so there's not really any sort of uh
consistency guarantee you need there
as long as you're running consumers on
you know both sides of network
partitions whether that's availability
zones or data centers or
racks and switches right you can
structure it in a way
we suggest running you know multiples
because that
makes handling failures easy but even in
the case of losing a lookup demon
you're not affecting your message flow
you're only affecting your discovery for
you know new clients that are starting
up or new you know publishers that get
a topic and if you got stale data from
lookupd
you'd simply try to connect and the guy
wouldn't be there right and you just
move on
likewise if somebody went down you know
and they came back online you just
wait till the next time right yeah
uh let's go back to this if uh if a
consumer is talking to one of these
nsqds
up at the top and that nsqt goes away
uh obviously like that tcp connection's
gone right from the consumer
so the consumer's just gonna wait to
pull the lookup demon again to ask
who should i connect to for this topic
and when
if that nsqd at the top comes back again
it'll register
the consumer will discover it again and
reconnect if not
and you've sort of like killed a host
purposefully and
you know you're moving your topology
elsewhere uh that's sort of what you
expect
i'm thinking about new consumers
so the find a stale host or they don't
find a host which is
the connections i think the connections
from
nsqd to the lookup demon are persistent
so the lookup demon only
knows which topics are where because it
has a persistent connection from that
nsqd
so as soon as it loses its connection it
doesn't give that information out
anymore
i think that was more what you're asking
right good yeah and we hard beat those
connections we heartbeat client
connections
and those are pretty tight so i would
say within 30 seconds
by default that stuff would sort of
clean itself
good question though
so as you can see as we've been
describing this in more and more detail
you can
you can imagine that the client has a
lot of responsibilities
and it's actually a really important
part of the system and we take great
care to build good client libraries
because that's really an important part
of the puzzle uh
so we mentioned before that messages are
pushed for performance reasons and
obviously because you don't want to sit
there and pull
latency and clients manage that
how much they are willing to accept uh
through something we call ready state
so when a client subscribes he'll
subscribe to the channel he's interested
send that command
and then he'll send a ready command
which says whatever number they send as
the value
i'm willing to accept this many messages
and you can use this for buffering for
asynchronous processing in the client uh
for performance for any
a number of reasons like that um
and an sqd will stop sending messages
as soon as that number on the server
side reaches zero so it's a it's a way
to flow control the
the data going to a client
and then we have other features in the
client libraries that allow them to back
off and slow down the rate of processing
so
if a client encounters some error with
the system it is writing to or
interacting with
it will send a ready zero to the nsqd's
that it's connected to and say hey slow
down
i have to deal with this for a second
it'll have some time out that fires
maybe
one second later maybe the next failure
as far as two seconds later
and exponentially backs off and
effectively slows down
the volume of messages it is receiving
and
also nsq gives you a really easy way to
kind of follow the same strategy on a
per
message basis um so if you have a
message that you're trying to handle and
you have some problem handling it like
say
you try to write it into the database
and you fail you can re-cue that
and give a certain time
frame as to when you want to handle that
message again
so if you fail you may not want to say
hey re-cue this and get it back right
away you might want to
say hey re-cue this give it back to me
in 30 seconds
and then you may try it a second time
and say hey i failed again
re-cue it give it back to me in 60
seconds so you kind of have also this
per message ability to sort of back off
and do
sort of exponential retries or just some
increasing window of retries
up to however many you've configured
your client to try
which is really powerful in handling
operations because if you have
say a database that goes down and you
have a
some you know cue reader that's
processing messages
trying to insert into that database what
you don't want to have happen is for it
to pile up
and say you have 100 messages a second
and you're down for three seconds
you don't want it to be trying 300
messages a second when you're trying to
start the database back up
so this sort of gives you ways to slow
down your
total rate of processing so that you can
actually recover systems and be able to
accept a request you're not sort of
overwhelmed by
requests initially and also if you have
a single message which is
say just strange something unexpected
something you didn't
uh like account for and you are unable
to process that message it gives you a
good way to sort of
handle that one message and and retry it
a couple times at different you know
delays and eventually say hey i'm not
going to
i'm not going to handle this i'm going
to write it at the disk for some
operations team to investigate like why
this message can't be processed
so it gives you ways to sort of handle
that if you have a couple messages that
are failing and still be able to sort of
process the rest of your messages
is there a question over here so um
so those messages get written at the
disk so there's no
uh the question is um
what happens on the channel side to the
messages when
a client is slow and is slowing down its
rate of messages right
so there's no hard-coded limit in terms
of number of messages you can store on a
channel
those just get persisted out to disk so
i mean
obviously at some point in time your
server's going to run out of disk space
but they're just appended to a log so
that's a really cheap operation
to do so the number of messages isn't a
problem
and all of these sort of flow control
and the rate of message processing is
handled on the client side
and we do that because uh oftentimes you
want to distribute your
clients that are consuming and say like
an easy case to think through is
we run a bunch of things in amazon and
amazon has different
data centers that they call availability
zones you might run
one reader for a channel
in one availability zone and another one
in a different availability zone
and one of those might have problems and
so it might slow down its
processing rate but it allows the other
one to still go at full blast so that's
why it's handled
the rate is handled client side not
server side
and it isn't uh you don't say i want
messages at 100 a second
you say right now i'm willing to accept
this many messages and that effectively
becomes your rate
based on how often you're sending that
command right
and a lot of people say well tcp kind of
does this right but it doesn't allow the
application to really control that
like like this does so often times you
say
remember normally queues are at zero so
normally you're saying
ahead of time like i'm ready for the
next hundred messages
and when those come in which they may
not come in depending on like what your
messages are
they get sent out and then the client
can finish those and say hey
maybe it only got one message and it
says back hey i'm still ready for 100.
so the demon will sort of know how many
messages that client is willing to get
yes
so the question is in the error scenario
have we seen
uh demons run out of disk space we we
used to
we would have seen that back in the day
we're a little bit better now
i mean we do pretty good for monitoring
that sort of thing so i don't know if
we've had any specific problems with
uh running out of disk space
well one of the point of failures right
like so
again we'd probably have maybe 15 20 of
these
producing that topic as a whole right so
if one node has issues it's a subset of
your entire stream right
so you wanna you wanna have layers of
degraded failure not complete and total
failure from a single broker right
it's better than losing everything
what do you mean by control the clients
because often this would be inside of an
infrastructure i wouldn't
typically expect people to expose this
uh anyone can find any application
yes
right so you're saying if there's a bad
client a you know a client that
misbehaves sends bad commands sends
invalid commands what happens
the answer is that we our approach is
always provide
a same default configuration with
balance so you can imagine
you're not able to just send hey send me
ready 14 million right you're able to
say
ready 2500 and it limits the impact that
a bad client can have and that
that includes message sizes body sizes
also at the end some of the
administration
interface which is pretty awesome for
being able to sort of know what
the state of what's happening and give
you visibility to when you do have a
client that's having problems
bad clients typically only screw
themselves up i've written them so i've
watched what they happened
right all
yeah so a couple other details that are
worth talking about
is in terms of cueing messages
sometimes uh there are cases where you
don't want messages to queue and you
want sort of the ability to do
ephemeral sort of introspection into the
messages that are flowing through
so nsq also has this way for you to
create a channel
and consume messages on it but just for
a short duration
and have it know that as soon as you
disconnect
your gun doesn't have to keep track of
messages for you you're not going to
come back which is really powerful and
i'm going to demo this
in a minute and then also in terms of
operational side it's really powerful to
be able to pause
messages and be able to do sort of
maintenance on systems
and i'm going to demo that as well
pretty fantastic i don't know if any of
you
guys deal with operations are actually
setting things up on servers and
having to do maintenance but it's
awesome
i know you're happy about this slide
right
this is let me get out of the way
so obviously there's a ton of other
solutions that exist in the marketplace
that do stuff like this
uh these are the ones we typically get
asked about why we didn't choose them
um does anybody have specific questions
like
again zero and q it's a library we'd
have to build a lot of this logic
we'd have to build demons that expose
your own qa
protocol ultimately it's just really
fancy sockets
and i did try to use that as the
protocol in between clients and demons
ultimately the reason why i abandoned
that approach was because it doesn't
really give you good visibility as to
what's in the queue and that's one of
the most important things
that we feel is uh you know an
operational property of the system that
we want to operate
um rabbit and q an active mq
good pieces of software just not
appropriate for the way we we view
the systems that we want to build again
this is opinionated software right this
works for us
we built it to fit right into our
infrastructure
exactly the way the old system used to
so as a result of that it's designed in
a certain way right
so if we would have chosen something
like rabbitmq or activemq we would have
had to have built
a lot of the infrastructure around it to
do the things that we needed it to do
and expose the right apis
kafka is another great piece of software
it's designed for a slightly different
use case
its goal is primarily throughput and
that isn't our only goal
it does a lot of other cool things and
it was certainly
inspiring some of our designs decisions
so you know we definitely respect that
as well as beanstalk and kestrel they're
all good
but again they don't they're not the
full package through what i would call a
platform messaging platform
um
so one of kafka's goals
as i see it is raw throughput right so
one of the way they structure things is
a client checkpoints the messages that
they're up to
so it isn't able to individually respond
and say i processed this message
and that's a really important quality
for a system like ours where we care
about
uh you have better granularity and
therefore better ability to
fail certain specific messages that are
causing problems
as opposed to just saying uh crap i have
to go back and get
the last 2500 again you know that's just
one example
also one of our primary goals was you
know easy to deploy so
some of these other ones are not so easy
to deploy go ahead
uh rabbitmq amqp
sort of promotes a brokered way of
viewing the world but you can do things
like slaving
and active active or you can just run it
inside of
like a federated mode where you run it
kind of how we run an sqd
it's a little bit heavyweight i would
argue if you did it that way
typically you'd have a set of rabbit mq
instances that you write to
one of them is responsible for a certain
topic
but of course the tradeoff is as a
result it has the ability i don't know
if it actually does to order messages or
do something like exactly once if that
even exists
beanstalk and kestrel are just kind of
cues with
cool apis castro is a really fast one
beanstalk is like memcache protocol
they're very similar in terms of
functionality to what our old
c app did and therefore wasn't really
resolving
some of the design goals that we had
uh not exactly the way i mean i mean
like i'm biased right
maybe somebody can enlighten me so i
mean
nsq architecture seems very similar to
kafka
right and did you look at kafka and
check it out or did you say we it
doesn't do that
we it was certainly on our list of
things to try yeah
we did look at it initially um i'm going
to admit we enjoy building new things
so part of that you know to be quite
honest we
yeah we wanted to experiment with go go
100 was approaching
we were sort of excited about the
features of the language we felt they
were a great fit for building something
like this and we were just inspired to
kind of go ahead and do it
and i think what came out of it is
something that's you know useful
that's why we're talking about it
obviously but
we're builders right
yes the question was
uh we didn't really evaluate any
specific vendors
of message tools and that's correct we
were looking for something that was open
source
so clearly we're using it in production
in bitly um so are a bunch of other
companies
any of you guys happen to be using it
we'd love to know about it and learn
about how it works for you
talk a little bit about some of the
tooling so we talked a lot about
how messages are sort of transported
between those pieces
there are some talk a little bit about
the tools that it gives you in terms of
being able to
understand what your topology is where
the messages are
what your data flow is like do any of
you guys use
graphite show of hands a couple
so nsq has built-in support for
sending statistics into graphite and
the charts you see pulled into the
administrative interface there are
coming straight out of graphite
uh which is pretty awesome it's
fantastic for giving you context
as uh you have messages that are backing
up when did it start
uh charting and sort of that trending is
important for that
and then there's a lot of smaller
utilities that just help with
being able to to troubleshoot things
being able to look at the messages that
are flowing through a topic
and escuda file is one we use very
heavily for archiving all of our data
streams out to disk
and most of those should be pretty
self-explanatory
um
you guys i'll put these slides up you
can you can click through on some of
this stuff
suffice to say that uh the clients end
up being really simple in terms of api
um you know come talk to me we could we
could show that later
so so john's gonna demo some stuff now
uh
we've reached sort of the end of our
slides are there any more questions
before we dig into set this up
no
the question is do we use any multicast
the answer is no
on the tcp level the multicast is
handled inside of the daemon
because we want all the sort of handling
of messages to be
handled by individual consumers that
have no knowledge about anything else
and so failure and retry of individual
individual
messages is uh very different than it
would be if you were sort of dealing
with multicast
uh yeah another question um
so the question is reading messages off
disk is done by the demon
uh when the daemon transparently uh
buffers things to disk
it will read those back in sort of
transparently you don't need to
deal with the fact that those are on
disk sort of we also described that we
archive things out to disk separately
we do that with that utility which is a
just a
random consumer which accepts the
messages and all it does is write it at
the file so that's sort of
completely independent of the demon
handling messages
the question is is the demon looking at
the watermark yes
so it looks at the watermark for when to
write them out to disk and
obviously it'll consume them back until
you're back to zero
it's gonna work here uh so you have to
look at the screen and do it ah
can you go turn on mirroring oh yeah all
right
stand by demos are hard
no actually technology's hard
okay can you hold the mic for me yeah
so uh jahi's gonna be demoing some of
those uh
utilities that we talked about before
this is one this is our live bitly
one of our bentley clusters of dynasty i
lied i'm gonna use the mic
um yeah so this is the admin interface
that shows you
uh messages and your topics and channels
so this is in one of our data centers
and i'm just going to drill through and
show you a couple of these so this is
sort of a view of
topics um you're probably not going to
know what half of these do which is okay
but we're going to go into a couple of
these so we have a message topic which
is sort of metadata about any api
request
and so the admin interface shows you
can you guys see that pretty well at the
top it shows you sort of
what where your nsqd's are that have
messages
so here we have four different hosts
that have these messages
and you can see uh sort of their current
depth is
zero or one uh and they're getting
you know each of them is getting about
50 messages a second here
and then we have three different uh
channels
on this so on this topic so each of
these channels is getting a copy of all
the messages
so if i go into one of these for this
stream metrics topic you'll see
this channel exists on each of those
same four hosts that have the messages
and you have a little more detailed
stats of how many messages are
outstanding in depth you know how many
are written to disk how many are
in flight to the client how many are
deferred which is
clients ask those to be re-queued and
it's not yet time to re-cue
to send them out and then uh just some
statistics on
uh total messages that you've handled
total number of requests and timeouts
that sort of thing
and number of connections from the
clients the bottom of the page is
details about individual connections
from a client
to an nsq daemon and
some of the metrics for that and so
remember
all the information about where topics
are in the your
cluster topology are is in the lookup
daemon so this admin tool
is querying the lookup daemon asking
where this topic is and then going to
query
those four hosts to get data to display
on this page
it's really important for us when we
build systems like this to have a lot of
hooks to be able to understand what's
happening right so this is a stats
endpoint
it can write out to the console and text
and you can just
kind of watch it on the command line we
often do that
we built utilities for you to be able to
tell it in aggregate
and obviously it exposes a json format
for you to suck it in
and use it however you want are you
storing the aggregates
the aggregates it's just querying
everybody and adding them
no coordination so i'm going to give a
little bit of demos and remember
one of the really powerful things for us
is to be able to decouple
the consumers from the producers so
we're actually going to look at some
live data now
and uh look at some of the command line
tools
and this is pulling data out of the
production cluster
which is really powerful without having
to go
update those primary systems that are
creating those messages and let them
you know give them additional
information about where to send messages
so a really important thing here is all
he's
saying on the command line is where one
of the lookup d hosts are
if you could scroll up
and the topic he's interested in and
everything else just sort of happens
for you so it's going to use that
lookupd host
whereas topic decodes finding out all
the producers and then querying them and
showing you iostatlike output
so this would be obviously far more
useful if things were actually backing
up
i think we'll do that in a second um so
again this is just for a different
topic and this is one of the channels
that's archiving things out to disk
and you can see here that it has a lot
of uh messages in flight
the reason for that is this client we
run it with a high number of
messages in flight so it will ask for
several thousand messages at once
and it will sort of wait for those you
know to come
in and then it will flush those out the
disk at once before
acknowledging back to the demon that
it's done with those messages so if it
sort of
dies and that host goes away before
those are synced out to disk
those messages won't be acknowledged and
they'll be given out to another host to
be persisted to disk
so you can use in-flight as sort of a
way to do sort of batch operations
and receive the messages before your
and then sort of separately acknowledge
that you're finished with them can i
pause this one
yeah okay i might pause it on that
what's that i'll do that at the end
um so this is a view into
that topic of api requests so again we
really like json because it's
easy um so this is sort of just in
production
introspecting into this data stream that
has metadata about our api requests
which as somebody who deals with
operations
this is really powerful to be able to
understand what's going on on our
systems without having to go on to
30 40 different machines and go tail
some logs and try to figure out what's
going
on so these are just json messages that
have a little bit of metadata about
individual api requests and i'm able to
pull those out using nsq tail straight
from
the individual demons with those
messages
and so now i'm going to do some fun
things we use
we have some cool helper tools to be
able to convert json to csv which is
really easy to work with on the command
line
so here i'm just pulling out three of
those fields from those json messages
just looking at the first 10 that i get
off the wire
and then we're going to do something
that's even cooler
which is i'm just going to pull out one
of those fields
the duration this is in milliseconds and
i'm going to get 500 of those
and just get a little histogram of that
so i've been able
right now we were able to see what the
response time is for
our production system for api employees
question
you're going to ask how many of these
demos i have right
so this is another tool that i've
written uh which is consuming these
messages
and just keeping track of the top uh
values that it sees so i'm able to sort
of again
connect right into our production data
stream and see right now
what the most requested api endpoint is
and the reason this one is the most
uh requested is we have a chrome
extension which pulls this
endpoint pretty regularly to sort of see
what traffic has happened on
a user's links um so again it's you know
consuming a lot of messages at once
i think i have another demo which
i'm going to consume a different stream
this is our actual click
decode stream and i'm going to look at
the countries that are clicking on links
right now and you can see this is
consuming
a couple thousand messages a second
right
and now final trick i don't remember
what the last one is
i don't know if we have an eight oh
that's it wait wait there's one more
so go do seven and let's go back into
admin we're going to show you pausing
so this is this is consuming our uh we
call it our decode stream which is all
the clicks that happen
um and so i'm going to go back in here
and we're going to find that
uh we're going to go into decodes here
and down under
channels there's this sketch ephemeral
channel
which if we go into
uh you can see it's consumed you know 41
000 messages and if i refresh here
you know 50 000 so in terms of
administrative interfaces
one of the things you can do which is
really powerful is just to be able to
pause
and so i've just paused this uh
channel and each of these four nsqd's
know it's paused
and they're not going to hand out any
more messages and so they're just going
to cue those they're just going to back
up so hold on hold on
go back one more thing that's going to
happen
soon is it will start writing a disk if
you see the memory plus disk column
well really what's going to happen is
i'm going to get paged here in a minute
as soon as this
overflows our limited oh wait actually
it's not gonna actually i'm gonna get
paid
oh correction dan frank over here is
gonna get paged
he's not gonna do it it's ephemeral
never mind
uh we can fix that so
back over here you'll see it's stuck at
55 000 messages
and then we can go unpause this
and uh we'll see this thing catch up
pretty quick
which is pretty awesome
so hang on a second i'll give you a demo
uh
that backs up yeah hold the mic
so the reason why i was trying to show
you with writing to disk but because
we used an ephemeral channel for that
demo uh
it would have just thrown away messages
beyond the uh high watermark
feature of ephemeral channels
so he's switching it to a non-ephemeral
channel so that when we
pause it you will actually get a backlog
so you'll see the ephemeral channel is
gone just because the client
disconnected the demons don't the
demons know not to keep that channel
around but
this sketch channel
is going to stick around so if i stop my
consumer over here
and we look over here we see there's
zero connections down here
on this channel and it's gonna back up
so this time
dan is going to get paged um but again
it gives you really
sort of easy administrative interfaces
we can go in and empty this queue
say hey i don't actually care about
these messages i just want to throw them
away
drop those off those cues are cleared
and then
you know if you've sort of moved on and
you're not
ever going to consume messages again and
you don't want it to back them up you
just simply delete the channel
i think that's all for my demo
okay
right so i think that's the end of our
slides here
thank you everybody
all right any other questions yeah uh
what type of hardware are you
uh using to run this uh technology
into one mediums yeah usually cb1
mediums are our favorite instant type
uh in aws um if we look
over here uh i'll give you a glance
this is sort of just an administrative
overview of the different demons and
what you can see they have different
topics
on the right hand side so we have a list
i don't know how many this is
did it say at the top 73 in aws
we have a bunch more in our primary data
center as well
the rows are yellow because it's showing
you that they are running old versions
it's useful yeah
any other questions yes
is there a security interface to
determine which client got connected to
which
topic is that your question can connect
no there's no protection if somebody
wants is aware of the existence of a
topic
and subscribes to it uh they will get
that there's no there's no built-in ssl
none of that yet something we've
considered could certainly be added
um and also of course depending on how
you decide to lay out your topology you
can certainly
apply network restrictions to you know
segment your topology if you want i was
just asking yeah
no good questions anybody ask
a fairly common uh that uh
slow consumer says don't send me any
messages
the nsu demon question yeah the question
the question you asked was is there any
facility to sort of guarantee latency
essentially would you describe it like
that
um the consumer has uh the message
that's coming to a client is sort of
framed
and in that is a time stamp that the
nsqd placed into it in nanoseconds
and you could use that as a basis for
deciding to discard messages
the client there's no way to tell the
server you know i'm running slow
uh yeah philosophically we believe that
those types of things should be in the
client
yes
so the question is if a consumer gets
disconnected and he goes through the
discovery phase and connects someplace
else
how does that work out um
um
so the uh your question is what happens
if the demon disappears
when the consumers got you know some of
the messages
uh yes so um
a message is owned by one producer right
it has
a globally unique id um
so if you connect it to a different
producer
because that original one that sent you
half of your messages
disappeared those me that other producer
knows nothing of those messages there's
no coordination right so you
the client libraries aren't written in a
way where they would do anything with
that they would just attempt
to send the message a command to the
original producer and fail to do so
you
most likely what would happen is you'd
reprocess those messages when the
original note
came back online because he wouldn't
have gotten the acknowledge
and therefore he would redeliver them
so the original fails client continues
to work
with other producers the original node
comes back online
client discovers and reconnects to him
and then receives those messages again
so at least once delivery it means you
can get it 50 times right
client libraries typically have some
configuration value where they say
uh if i've seen a message after five
attempts i'm gonna just
automatically discard it and write it to
some temporary directory or
syslog you know whatever i think we have
time for one more question
if there is one
on internationally yeah each other and
in terms of what we just outlined here
you
see like in the future where you might
break this down and even more simpler
services
so the question is along the lines of
our philosophy of sort of breaking
things down into small
components uh i think we've already done
that which is sort of why there's a
separate
demon that handles messages a separate
demon that handles sort of the lookup
data for discovery and a separate daemon
that gives you
sort of the admin interface so those are
already like three
completely independent pieces like if
you don't want to use the lookup demon
for discovery
you don't have to you can you know hard
code your clients connect to one
you know and ask askewd if that's all
you have so to some extent i think we've
already done that
uh always open to feedback on other ways
that that could sort of be approached
we also didn't really talk much about go
because it didn't seem appropriate but
one of the nice things about go is that
it's statically compiled so
it's literally just a binary you can
copy around if you you could even cross
compile
on osx into linux and copy that binary
over and just run it i mean
everything is configured on the command
line no config files not that many
dials so they are actually really small
components they are lightweight
they don't take up a lot of resources
except some memory and some disk in
certain cases right
cool thank you very much
you